so this movie is inspired by the real
files of the character you play so it
was making me wonder if you could maybe
give us an example of something you saw
in those files or learned about his true
experience that made you you know stop
and go like no way this is possible no
way this ever happened but the more you
learned about him maybe the more you
believed well that's actually
you know the the key thing for me on
this was getting fascinated by him
you know
um I know it makes me seem very naive
but I had no idea there was a job called
the chief Exorcist of the Vatican I was
like oh no okay I thought that was
something that somebody had made up you
know and then I looked it up and
realized it was real and then
you know just tracking back through
father of moth's life
and it's a fantastic Journey it's a
fascinating Journey you know we we
allude to it a lot in in the movie
there's there's sequences where you know
we go through his journey because you
know you're talking about
a young boy who grows up in modern in
Italy which is also where Ferrari comes
from which is why there's a couple of
Ferrari references he wears red socks
under his classic any has a Ferrari
sticker on islamber at a motor scooter
but um
you know the age of 17 he travels to
Rome he believes he's had a calling to
serve God and he he gets to Rome talks
to priests and the priest says you're
too young
so basically sends him back home come
back when you have more experience
so now you find this kid who goes back
to Modern it's 1942. the second world
war is Raging
and this young man who who believes he's
had a call and to serve God finds
himself with a gun in his hand and he's
shooting to kill
goes through his War experiences comes
out of those War experiences and goes
into law school gets his law degree then
starts working as a journalist
goes back to the same priest it's seen a
decade earlier
and says I still have this calling and
the priest this time says well that's
perfect because now you've lived some
life and you've got something to teach
and you know so he goes into theology
school
comes out of it starts working
um with the powerless and that order is
all about communication so he produces
radio he produces television he starts
writing hundreds and hundreds of
articles for intra Church magazines
and
deep into his life the age of 60.
he's tapped on the shoulder by a a
priest he didn't know very well called
father candido
and father candida was the chief
Exorcist for the Vatican and he says
Gabriella you have to take over from me
and this is like it just came out of the
blue for him he had no association to to
you know that part of the church
you know but then 36 years as Chief
Exodus for the Vatican
12 books documenting his personal
experiences now
I began to Believe In Father and moth
through reading about his life
experiences
so by extension
if he's written it down in a book he
didn't make it up
so there it is I'm gonna wind up going
down that rabbit hole after this and
reading some of that I did it with the
conjuring movies and the Warrens and
it's going to happen again I feel it
gotcha the first book or the first two
books really right I mean if they don't
shake your foundations nothing will you
know but it's it's definitely worth
looking into that's the kind of
bringing up shaking someone's
foundations there's a lot of qualities
in him in the movie that say the
opposite where no matter how much
Darkness he goes through he always has
this light-heartedness and levity to him
when you're playing a character like
that who deals with so much but can keep
things light where do you think that's
coming from in him well you know
the result of of that deep dive that I
did you know it distilled down to two
things for me you know there's a purity
of his faith
his belief is unquestionable right and
and you can see when people are with him
and they've talked about it you know and
look I met colleagues of his I met
um friends of his I met a man who did
160 exorcisms with him you know and the
way they talk about father and moth
not necessarily that he's on a pedestal
but he's he's certainly in his own rare
air you know they talked about him with
a great deal of respect you know and you
think about a man who has to constantly
deal with Afflicted people and the
Darkness that those people are going
through the darkness that their families
are going through
you know and one thing that became
really clear is he had this crazy sense
of humor you know and people there's two
things right impurity of faith and a
sense of humor if you're facing that
kind of Darkness
constantly on behalf of other people if
you're the man reaching into somebody
who's in trouble trying to bring them to
the lot
then the purity of your faith and a
sense of humor that's got to be the best
sword and shield that you can have in
terms of protecting yourself you know in
that in that moment you know I I think
one of the things he talks about quite a
lot in in the books you know he says the
devil doesn't have a sense of humor
devil hates jokes
you know but the one thing that the
devil looks for is the people who you
know instead of jeering directly at the
Devil jeer at the concept of a devil
because if they start to believe evil
doesn't exist they're the people that
evil
are available to evil potentially right
before they kick me out of here I have
to look ahead a little because we got a
lot of people out there that read our
site that are really looking forward to
the Gladiator Sequel and I know you're
not in the movie but I've heard you say
that you've been kept in the loop on
development so now from the perspective
oh I'm sorry I never said that okay well
I mean in in that case you're you're
still in the audience perspective now
watching that movie watching that movie
come together is there anything that you
as a key part of the original film or
are hoping to see in another installment
of that now film series I I don't really
know where they're going to go with it
um I'm sure
that there's been things on Ridley's
mind for the last 24 years that he
thinks he can probably do better or
something
you know I think that's one of the
positives about it for sure that it is
um Ridley you know because he's going to
want to
uh go back into that world and create
something the same level of spectacle as
the first one you know
um I mean look the only thing that I
really feel about it is slightly jealous
you know because that was that was a you
know a
you know as a much younger man obviously
and um it was a huge experience in in my
life and uh
you know it's something that um
I mean it you know it changed my life
really changed the way people regarded
me and what I do for a living and you
know I've been very lucky to be involved
in lots of uh big movies but um you know
the legs on that film are incredible you
know here this is 2023 and we made that
film in 1999. I guarantee you somewhere
around the world tonight Gladiator is
going to be showing on Primetime TV and
you don't always get that kind of
longevity with every film you do so
um it's obviously a you know holds a
special place in my heart not do better
build upon that's the key I look forward
to see what they're doing on that huge
congratulations on the Pope's Exorcist
and thank you for your time today thank
you very much